the US Treasury market is deep it's wide
its liquid it is the safe haven and all
safe havens yet there's a lack of
liquidity and that is being blamed for
the the sell-off today is that is that
reasonable to you yeah I think there is
a lack of liquidity I think it's largely
due to positioning I think people got
themselves very comfortable that the
growth year had slowed down and wasn't
growing that there were problems in
Europe that Europe wasn't gonna get its
connect together I don't sudden I think
you got this trifecta that's really
hitting you've got fundamentals always
something look better ADP was decent
you've got the technicals where the
positionings wrong everyone's talking
about how low bund yields are that's no
longer true and finally you have this
catalyst which i think is a deal for
greece but you know when you take a look
at the bomber i get that's where people
go for safety right unless you're in
high-yield I mean is this gonna
fundamentally change the way investors
viewed as asset class okay people have
been waiting for this for a long time
right that the bond market is going to
see the end of its 30-year incredible
rallied bull markets over it's gonna be
the lack of a safe haven not a safe
haven there's that is to be determined
at this point whether we've really seen
the start of that move but what you are
seeing is more volatility in bonds and
even stocks and to to Peter's point what
you're seeing is people have just
plummeted into the same assets for years
and now even now they don't really want
to wholesale sell because they don't
know is this the real thing or not so
what you're seeing is trading at the
margins that are shifting around the
values in this market by hundreds of
billions of dollars each day and causing
a big tantrum but people aren't locking
in necessarily those losses by actually
selling their holdings in masks Peter
look what you tweeted earlier today
which is markets always revert to the
mean the question is which mean do we
revert to are we seeing that right now
yeah I think that's one of the things
we've been seeing we've been seeing
buying of the dips in the Treasury
market because everyone's looking well
it's your much cheaper than it was a
month ago when we were 188 or and I
think the realistic issue is that we
were at 260 on the 10-year last summer
we've added over three million jobs
since then so why isn't to 60 or more
realistic level so I think people are
focused a little bit too much on the
near-term relative value and I think we
got to go back a bit longer to him and
that's why this sell-off has more room
to go well we were talking before we
came on camera about how really what's
at play here is inflation the models for
inflation have really broken down we
don't
sense i mean the money printing of
central banks has an ignited inflation
yet people are questioning what will and
all of a sudden you're seeing inflation
starting to tick up and people are
wondering is this going to be it its
inflation really going to search what's
the trajectory of this and the sell-off
is really in the 30-year bonds the
10-year bonds not the two-year bumps not
this is not a federal sure what does
that mean this is not a Federal Reserve
spurred sell-off this is an inflation
this is this all that inflation and
we've also seen yelling on that subject
moving the goalpost a little bit
Bernanke add everyone focused on pc eee
pc has not been showing signs of
inflation but she has gone out of her
way to say we have to look at
alternative measures and there are
alternative measures that are showing
higher inflation i want to turn this
into a Greek discussion but speaking of
moving goalposts what is the link to
Greece if any will a last-minute
resolution in Greece on friday on sunday
night has so many to expect to halt the
selling no i think that will actually
make the selling go faster here i think
what you'll see is a risk on trade so
we're already seeing it in Europe where
buns and French oats were selling off
but spanish and italian bonds were
rallying so i think the whole flight to
safety bid that's been out there will
disappear so buns and treasures will
continue to sell off and i do expect a
deal given what we're hearing what we're
seeing and what really is is Draghi i
think wants a deal merkel now wants a
deal so a deal will happen i just have
to say i was looking at my world bond
screen on the Bloomberg terminal and it
was you know every bond was like in the
red in the red in the red in the red
there was one green spot and it was
Greece and it was sort of this ironing
you know of the whole thing this has
always been the red spot now it's green
we're up bonds are gaining so reverting
foot mean exactly you take a look at
across the bond market with corporate
high-yield sovereigns is there a market
that has adjusted to this volatility
that we've seen question not really so
far I think the credit markets so
investment grade in high yield have held
in very well so if you look at some of
the ETS whether it's hyg or J&K they're
down a little bit today but they've
definitely outperforming the Treasury
market so so far I think people been
very reluctant to sell their corporate
bonds is that a risk on trade it's part
of its partly cuz its risk on so you're
seeing equities up so that's one reason
to hold on to them and then too I think
people are extremely worried about the
liquidity so if they sell their
corporate bonds in a moment of fear they
might not be able to buy them back so I
think we need another leg down and we
need to see equities lead the way before
we see credit spreads wider and to that
point I mean the volatility that we're
seeing is
really that traumatic yet or is it
really just the concern of how bad it
will get right I mean if it just keeps
going and going and going and you don't
feel like there's a bottom like you did
at some points in May in late May of
2013 that could become a problem but
this you know the Blitz and moves are
not kind of a lot of investors also feel
comfortable that they own a 30-year
corporate bond with a four and a quarter
percent coupon and that's value they
don't feel as comfortable owning a two
percent tenure but they'll own petra by
100 year bond for eight and a quarter
see the coupon point I have to ask you
to break down liquidity for us a lot cuz
we use that word constantly and we have
a lot of global liquidity thanks to the
European Central Bank thanks to the
Federal Reserve the Bank of Japan
chasing yield across asset markets but
we have relatively limited treating
liquidity yeah and that's one of things
I look at and one of the things that's
concerned me over the past couple weeks
is in the Treasury market you will see a
lot of trading at a very at a specific
price so a lot of back and forth in a
very narrow price range but as soon as
someone comes in with a larger move it
instantly gaps wider which tells me that
it's really people kind of scalping
whether it's all goes in there all sorts
of you know i'll call it fo liquidity is
it looks like there's lots of liquidity
but it's only for that very narrow price
range the second you start gapping
everyone's out and it resets and comes
back in at that new higher or lower
price is this whole game change once we
see the Federal Reserve stop reinvesting
they're maturing securities and they
actually start to tighten well we've
already seen it hit in the off the run
Treasury so all the Treasuries that the
Federal Reserve have been buying all
these high coupon longer data Treasuries
so the off the run 20 to 30 year bonds I
have become very illiquid they are hard
to get good pricing on you're not
accurately priced we're even seeing some
discrepancies where TLT which is an ETF
that references them is training and so
that's very different i think that's a
big function the Fed was the big buyer
of this so no one knows where the value
is on these bonds so they've lost that
liquidy which again points to this whole
lack of you know true in-depth liquidy
and value CP price discovery once ago